so yeah my name is Sarah
they'd said then I'm going to share a
little bit of a story of how we built a
system to avoid model drift or data
Drift actually not all of the data
drifts but some of them and we did it
with a human Loop because actually
that's part of tolka Heritage and
tolokis yeah
is where I worked out and
I think I'd like to probably start with
asking you how many of you have
implemented any human Loop pipelines
before you know somehow combined humans
and machines right one two
oh and it's not not bad okay some people
are going to learn something new and for
those of you who have uh just going to
share with you some also yes hopefully
some new infrastructural ideas
um all right well so very briefly about
me I studied I did PhD in London and
then moved did worked in in Amazon
Microsoft AWS now running AI in teloka
and
the whole talk is going to be is going
to have like four parts uh we're gonna
talk about overall philosophy philosophy
of changing environments and things that
change over time in our life and then um
uh how does this actually Encompass
itself and show itself in the deployed
machine learning models then we're going
to move towards water we actually build
internally for our systems
um so kind of sharing experience with
you and then I'm going to move towards
actually showing some industry in
research use cases which benefit from
having such a system or which just
benefit from kind of the human look at
them well first of all about you know
about the changing world I mean world
changes quite often and a lot
and parts of those changes come from you
know changes in context when uh you know
a simple example where you built a say a
classifier for
um for sentiment of the reviews uh and
then you wanted to use that classifier
to find bad products and and then maybe
there was some scented candles there was
a product and some reviews which
indicated that the candles don't have
scent actually say that they indicate
that probably that product is bad and
before kovit that was the case and now
after covet
um having a product having candles which
don't have Ascent doesn't really mean
that they are bad product maybe
um maybe maybe the person who is just
basically sick at the time
another situation with is an emergence
of new phenomena
so that
um that encompasses itself if you
remember if you actually received any
spam mails in the past they all looked
like you know some Nigerian prince
um is is happy to give you a few million
dollars just just you know maybe a few
hundred you have to send them just just
you know to for the uh for the
transaction to go through and now uh the
spam emails they they look much
different they look very similar to how
the real person from a real company
would write to you and of course the old
spam classifier is not going to work for
a new situation and you know the new
styles of the
um
of the letters now some of the words
have new meanings and you know if you
were to ask uh or to you know Google
search uh something about Tesla uh 10 15
years ago you'd think about Nikola Tesla
and now the majority of searches are of
course about about the company or about
the car
so this this changes they of course
somehow if you have a model deployed
they somehow you know translate
themselves into the deployed model so
how do they do this
well um we had a case where a company
was building self-driving cell driving
system and they collected a ton of data
and they had really good system but they
were they were in the like prototypes
thesis and so they wanted to go to a
contest and the constant contest was
happening sometime in October and so
they were already and then about a week
before the context what contest what
happened was that a snow fell and and uh
and the completely it completely changed
the whole environment and the models
which were deployed they couldn't of
course work in that situation they had
to they had to update their models and
you know change things
um now another client had a had a case
with um social media classifications
they were collecting uh they were
collecting a lot of data
uh
a lot of different social media
mentionings of their of their company
and so they had to classify those
mentions into those which are relevant
to their company and those which are not
and they had a certain recall and
precision requirements and because they
had certain Precision memory
requirements they actually had to send
some of those examples to humans for
checking and those are about half of all
of the examples they collected all of
the social media mentionings and after
you've have some sort of a system which
this is like a hint of what I'm going to
talk about today after you have the
system which updates itself or which
actually takes and takes care of
um you know model
incorporates the recency into the model
uh you know you you can really reduce
that's what they did they reduced the um
budget they reduced the amount of money
they spend on human labeling
now if you think about you know this
fancy new
um Chinese things about gpts and and you
know maybe maybe the great big large
language models can avoid these
situations and of course they don't
um a simple way to check is you can ask
chargpt when
it's training data finished and it uh
the training did for chargept ended in
September 2021 and then if you asked
something like when was the last
earthquake in Turkey it's going to tell
you about the 2021 earthquake in turkey
and not the recent one
now so um so what did we do for you know
to avoid this kind of use case because
people come to us with the questions of
you know well can you build me a model
or can you you know leave me some data
so um we did this so-called adaptive
models uh but the reason why we did this
is kind of the heritage of locus that
look historically is a
um data labeling company based on
crowdsourcing and uh it used to only
focus on the crowdsourcing data labeling
now we have kind of two key components
of our product of machine learning
models which are pre-trained and ready
to be adapted to the customer use case
and again the local is like a huge crowd
actually it's about 100 countries in I
think 40 plus languages and so those can
those are able to adapt the models to uh
whatever application
um comes in you know whatever language
comes in and as needed and so we produce
this human power machine learning
Solutions we have we focus a little bit
on Solutions of course a lot on the
actual product so you are able to build
those Solutions yourself
and uh and what we did internally for
these adaptive models is that we thought
about you know about the whole process
of building a model and if you think
about the process I mean you collect the
data you clean the data so all sorts of
different steps and so we said well how
about we replace the middle part of this
process by so-called adaptive models uh
and um
we did it um we did it in a in a way
that now
our solution architects who build
systems they are only able to they only
need to in order to build something is
you know to build it like end-to-end
working AI solution they need to only uh
do the first two-step which is explain
how to label data explain basically in
human language what they need to do and
then the models are like this this
concept is um
of internal product is able to uh take
care of itself take care of retraining
and remonitoring
um at the same time uh in at the same
time as the production goes on
all right how does this work in the
background so um if you think about
models models the service uh
then there's a model hosted somewhere
it's getting pinged through the API and
there is a database where the
predictions are stored and the API
basically sends some of the examples
there and this is this is kind of a
normal way of doing ml as a service
so what we did is that we added an
additional component here which is here
it's called the local project and the
local project is a data labeling project
recently takes the human explanations of
how the data instructions how the data
should be labeled or what you actually
need out of this out of every label and
then
for every item which gets into the API
part of the items some of the items get
into the local project then the
go to the crowd and it's all stored
again back into the database and as you
can see there is this Arrow from
database to model and back and and the
reason why the server exists is because
some of the model's predictions are
stored in the database but also the data
from the database are used to retrain
the model
um and of course you know monitor it at
the same time and we used our normal you
know whatever it uses components for for
the system we base our ml things on
Azure ml then we um
have data breaks for actually storing
the database and kubernetes for
automatic scaling
now what happened in production was
actually a curious use case so that's a
story about that about the same social
media uh social media monitoring
company
and here you can see on the right Axis
on a horizontal axis you have
uh dates and our workouts you have more
performance so you have this model you
know increasing accuracy over time very
fast until it gets to a point where okay
well no more data is really necessary to
uh train it to uh to whatever it can
achieve but then as you see the the the
the line kind of drops down slowly and
that actually happens because the data
becomes more complicated you know the
kind of the distribution of the changes
but the model still adapts it now every
point is a retraining attempt for like a
new event right so I knew maybe like
once a day or once a week well in this
case I think it's once a week
oh
no this is fat okay this is more wrong
yeah this probably once in three days
retraining happens and what evaluates
itself and you put a point there and you
see the point started going down but the
pink line is above and the Reason Pink
line is well it's pink line is the model
which is deployed in production and the
dotted line started going down because
we introduced the bug in the system and
so we introduced the bug the model
didn't train very well but the model in
production was still performing well and
so of course this doesn't really say
that the external environment changes
and we adapted to it but but what
happened is that the system adapted to
the internal changes the fact that the
bugs were the bug was introduced and I
mean
who writes a code without bugs raise
your
alarm please
hand
all right so basically what we did of
course like we tried to think about all
right now
um like where's where's the place for
this sort of a technology and you know
there are models of service things like
AWS recognition or Azure content
moderation those are very cheap but
those are not adapted to the database
data set that you have at hand and then
the next step people do is lower rate
what that model doesn't work for me
let's go to Hanging face nowadays and
let's just take a hugging phase model
and then and you know train it and then
deploy it and then support all the
deployments this is very expensive
because you actually need people who
know how to do this and probably not one
person and it's hard to experiment with
very many different models and if you
like if you don't build one system but
if you build many systems it's
um better to actually pre-build the
whole of infrastructure so you have to
hire the whole infrastructure team so we
did hire the infrastructure team who
built this thing but we've built this
once and now the solution Architects are
able to go somewhere in it in the Middle
Ground here
well now let's I guess move towards a
real kind of real situations in Industry
use cases
and some research ones as well
um well one of these Keys is what
Quantum moderation with public messages
was a
provider of actually a public
[Music]
messenger and they had so-called like
public channels where everybody could
post uh things and some of those things
which someone posted were illegal and
the messenger uh had to filter them out
and actually find those bad
channels or communities or whatever you
want to call them and they had an
internal moderation team and they didn't
really have a model to track this and
they spending in same mode they were
spending insane amount of money on this
and they were only able to cover like a
single language with that internal
moderation team so we've built this
thing for them this solution customized
for them with three different languages
and what happened was that it ended up
in reducing their escalation numbers
by 30 to 40 percent which is pretty cool
and now of course they increase the
amount they're able to scale the volume
up so one of the things which I am as a
I guess historically machine learning
person is fascinated
um with when used crowdsourcing is this
automatic way of scaling things up when
you have like an internal moderation
team uh it you know sits if you have
like a good you know good few days it
sits and doesn't really do anything and
then when
something bad comes out I'm Rick I'm
being recorded So when something bad
comes out then
um what you have to do is you have to
hire more people or you actually have to
ask some of your
um full-time uh full-time Engineers to
go and moderate some data because
otherwise your site website is
overflowing with or in this case your
message is overflowing with it with the
bad messages but crowdsourcing approach
actually allows you to not think about
that at all because the more data you
have the more people see the task and
they come and they execute the task and
you know you don't you don't think about
scaling this up now
um I like the showing I like showing
this slide because it scares people and
it's not like I like scaring people but
it's it's kind of the idea of this Slide
the only thing which which you can
probably learn which you can probably
get out of it is is human labeling is
not like you make a description of the
task and you're done this is not how it
works unfortunately in order to work
with these human creatures what you need
to do is that you need to really explain
how to do the task and then you really
really need to really check that the
person
is able to do those tasks and then
regularly check that this person still
wants to do those tasks well and also
even then people make mistakes so you
end up having to ask three people maybe
for an opinion and then average their
opinion there's some sort of majority
vote to David scheme this happens here
um and then uh and then if you want like
real high accuracy then in the cases
which are very ambiguous maybe you know
two people said this cat one person said
it's a dog uh you feel like it's you
know it may be ambiguous case then you
need to ask even more people and and
maybe like up to seven and then weigh
them out to actually get the right
answer and so this allows you to do what
this allows you to actually reduce
um
I'm going to talk later about what it
really in theory allows you to do but
here like you have a machine learning
model right it's confident about some
examples confident about some other
examples in the middle you send this to
humans
but you don't understand it just humans
can get great results I mean you send
this to humans they agree and then you
get the result but they disagree and
then you send it to more humans and then
they you know hopefully agree and if all
of them disagree then you basically can
manually look at the the result and
check it out and see if your
instructions are bad or you know it's
just a really weird case
now another uh
varium popular and kind of useful
um useful um
application of the concept of human and
loop is is the application of processing
converting handwritten digits or ratings
into
um
into actually not handwritten once I
needed the digital ones and uh
uh if you you know if you take any of
the models available out there none of
them I'm going to give you perfect
accuracy and uh quite often in order to
get really high accuracy you need for
the complicated case you need to ask
humans to in this case verify what uh
the model is doing
and again like I mean I'm not going to
go through the business details but long
story short is you're getting higher
accuracy you're getting uh slower faster
speeds with crowdsourcing and higher
accuracy than the manual only
um other than the automatic only
recognition now this
as I mentioned there is this process of
checking the model which produced
something and that is slightly different
than in the moderation cage so in this
case the model actually produces some
outputs and then there is a
the steps are that you you verify the
output of the model with humans and if
it's not correct then only then you you
correct it and all of this all of these
different things are you know different
small tasks which you need to check
right I'm realizing that
recording is probably not going to be
fun with uh with my head on the right
and my microphone on the left but
I guess there's some magic with the with
sound which is going to be which is
going to be able to be done right so so
again like uh this is what
so what I was telling you is like what
are the reasons why you know human
oversight here is is needed in very many
other cases is you can quite often
achieve much higher accuracy in a human
only approach and you are able to
sustain the model performance over time
now we can move towards uh research use
cases those are a little more
um on the edge which which is where the
research is supposed to be so in this in
this particular case we
attack of the problem of finding the
best prompts I don't know if you any of
you played with them oh yeah like has
anyone played with the image generation
models like stability diffusion those
those kind of things
right
oh no okay so for those of you who
haven't played with the image generation
models there's a lot of fun things to do
you can do now on the internet uh there
are um there are models which are host
and you can give them the commands like
generate me landscape or generate me a
portrait and recently the most recent
news is they generate me a portrait of
um uh of the of the Pope in uh
a puff in a puff jacket and I was a I
actually generated some not very fun
um
uh controversies because basically the
model was able to generate a really very
trustworthy looking picture of the Pope
uh wearing a puff jacket and like he's
wearing the super fancy very expensive
jacket and of course a generated picture
but it was generated controversy that
hey or maybe he's actually he bought it
somewhere in Milan or somewhere else so
people started you know arguing about
those things and so anyway so but the
thing is to generate really good images
right now what you need to do is you
need to find those prompts and those
prompts are basically like magical words
so maybe you want to say you want to
generate a portrait of
yeah I poured it over a queen and then
um
and then what you need to do is you need
to put some words some magical words in
the beginning and in the end so that the
image is good and what are those words
how do you find them and you know a
natural approach is I mean you go online
and you say oh I'm gonna take the top
Words which people use I'm just going to
plug them into the prompt and what
happens is that might not be the best
approach so we we've designed a
different approach to do this and what
we did was that we've um
we took a variety of prompts like all
the collection of different keywords
which people use for making the prompt
and we've made those sets of keywords
from uh from those uh from that large
set of keywords and we've designed a
task for cloakers for human performers
to compare different images with each
other say which of the image they like
more
um relevant relative to the promptage
was given you know in the previous case
uh the task would be hey
um the user gave me the prompt of
generating an image of a queen which of
these two images you like more so by
collecting large amounts of such data
you're able to get feedback on what
prompt collections uh what keywords
work better than other keyword sets and
then we change we've
used genetic algorithm to actually
evolve those sets of keywords in order
to get
um like a final set of keywords which
works better and so we found some
keyword this is open you know open
research you can find this on archive
and it was a I think in Europe's yeah it
was a Europe's Workshop uh last year
um
so we found some keywords which work
better according to humans so now what's
the idea here right like the idea which
I want to kind of pass over here is that
human feedback is essential to learn
what humans prefer and and if you want
to know like if you want your models to
produce something useful
something nice something pleasant
something aesthetically pleasing then
you might need to adapt those to human
preferences and this would be basically
did here now another one is um
uh task of learning from subjective data
where we've basically again this is a
pairwise comparison and we're trying to
learn like can you actually train a
model which
says which image of a person looks older
or younger than another image right and
and looks older than younger is not like
guessing the age guessing age is you
know is one thing and especially really
hard because you need to
um get some sort of a floating Point
number but uh learning which one is you
know older or or
younger is again a subjective task and
so it turns out with this pairwise
comparisons you can do that now another
thing is
another research application we've done
was is the application of um
RL HF which is now a popular uh popular
technique for aligning machine learning
models who heard about the rhf
okay well people more people than played
with image models that's
good statistics right well okay so early
Chef is um
um it's a long story short if you train
a large machine or any model uh you
usually train it on whatever internet
data is there but then it produces some
hallucination some really like
totally weird unreal things and so in
order to make it be more realistic like
give answers which make sense to humans
there's a process of aligning alignment
uh called the reinforcement feedback now
this is not about this this is basically
the same kind of idea is what if you
want to design a reward function and you
don't know how you don't know like what
is a good answer from a model and what
is a bad answer from the model like you
don't you don't obvious you don't have
an obvious judgment out of this right in
games when you do reinforced learning
for games you have a score and then you
know if the character of a game jumps
somewhere and falls into lava then you
know your score uh reduces to zero and
it's just a very immediate feedback now
in many cases you don't have such an
immediate feedback I mean realistic
cases and so what you can do is that you
can and you guessed it like do side by
side comparison so what we did is that
we took the open AI reinforcement
learning agent and we wanted we wanted
to do I we wanted to
make it do a backflip but without
actually training a reward function and
so we've shown to humans
um
video clips short video clips of this
thingy trying to do something and then
ask you know which of these uh is closer
to
to do a backflip and this way you
basically you know we're able to find
to find a policy which
um which makes the agent do a backflip
um
well I've already shared this but
basically yeah like the thinking here is
that if you want to learn something
subjective if you don't know what is
if you don't know in your situation a
very good definition of what is good and
what is bad ask people to provide you
with feedback
okay so now um
this is an important topic nowadays of
of what's uh what's in the generative
models you know maybe maybe
um
AI is going to take over at some point
and maybe
all of this is not going to be needed
because you can go and ask GPT okay who
heard about GPT
all right
it was just more like a
I don't know either someone lives in a
cave or is a passive audience
to to two options here all right so uh
part of the audience
I want to correct myself all right so
basically who's you know who who can be
man we've started doing some conversions
we've done some more comparisons we
haven't published them yet so I don't
want to share them but like so we did it
and we've um
uh taking it to a task which uh is a
very simple you know popular task for
review classification let's say and uh
we've got an accuracy of 88 versus 96 so
here talkers are somewhat better
um and then we took another another
classification uh which was uh I don't
actually remember what that specific
task was but was uh very clearly
um a very clear advantage of the locals
uh on top of torokers versus gbt3 now
what uh you know these slides are not
going to give you like too much Insight
but one of the Insight I want to pass
here is that gbd models and whatever the
models are currently deployed they're
really good to interact with they're
very intuitive they seem to produce
really impressive results but they're
not attentive they are not really paying
attention to whatever task you give it
to and not really exact and so this is
so far the conclusion we've we've
actually made if you have a very
specific task then
so far the humans win but nobody knows
what's going to happen later
all right um
so oh yeah but like this was these were
classification tasks now one of one of
the important
um
also insights which uh which I share
here is there are tasks like text
generation or name density organization
like creative tasks like image
generation right for those
the models you know sometimes do a good
job sometimes not and what you can do
with the human feedback is you can pick
the best ones you can say okay well this
one is good this one is not good you
know you can say
um you can moderate your outputs if you
use them in production you can moderate
your outputs to say that you know this
is actually appropriate to have to be on
my website and or in my support chat and
whatever whatever you're implementing
and this is not
well that's it um happy to answer any
questions and it's going to be probably
office hours later on um so maybe they
answer any questions of the office hours
as well
thank you for listening
[Music]